is Alex Jones helping you out actually
I'm kind of disappointed in Alex huh he
is not selling the iconic Roger stone
did nothing wrong t-shirts which is you
know been a mainstay of my fundraising
by the way you can get the mitt
1776 back shop why isn't he selling them
I was t-shirt I was arrested in and he's
not selling them I've expected a nice
contribution to my Legal Defense Fund I
have not received one I'm a little
disappointed
would you consider a nice contribution
it's all about a week ago he said that
his testimony or his comments on Sandy
Hook something by the way I've never
spoken about it all or written about was
caused by psychosis he did say that yep
and then Saturday I saw a video in which
he said posses of men dressed as clowns
are going around abducting children for
sexual abuse I hope he's all right
I don't know so you're a little upset
that Rogers sir I mean that our lives
that Alex Jones is not helping you out I
mean you did Alex Jones a show for a
long time pretty loyally you are no
legal stuff going on too though he does
have you I am grateful for Alex Jones
for giving me a platform he is a friend
of mine I like the guy I like hanging
out with him I do not agree with
everything he says I agree with some
things he probably doesn't agree with
everything I say but you know a check
would be nice have you reached out to
him and say hey it was very very
successful and very very profitable and
hopefully he'll he'll throw a few
samolians my way now way to consider a
good would you consider a nice donation
of samolians 25 large would make me
happy it would be good have you told him
hey Roger a big chunk it be chump change
for him he has a very very successful
operation
have you told Alex I mean brilliant
brilliant model I mean he is simulcast
on 200 plus radio stations the same time
he's got of high-quality video
presentation simulcast and he's uh you
know and he has no sponsors because he's
his own sponsor he sells his own
products and they shall briskly by the
way I've used a lot of a lot of more
very good have you told him hey Alex I'd
really like about $25,000 please well
I'm not gonna get into our personal
conversations back of course one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the Sirius XM
app